[Music]
last year was like a really defining
year of my life I'm really excited to be
on the other side of that year and I'm
excited to not know what I'm excited
about
that's what Kelsey told us just five
days after her new boo Chase Stokes made
their relationship insta-official with
this cuddly pick and yesterday the 29
year old dropped a six song short film
breaking down her 2022 divorce from
Morgan Evans
the lyrics revealed he got half in their
split how their busy careers created
distance in the marriage and the exact
summer week she took off her ring
Kelsey's authentic words are what fans
love and what she'll dive into on CMT
storytellers Kelsey ballerini airing
tomorrow night we were exclusive on set
I feel like sometimes you know when
you're glittery and blonde people forget
that you also are craftable for me it's
it's the most important part of what I
do and it's the thing that I want to be
known for I love all sides of what I get
to do as an artist but like I think the
the purest part is songwriting and I
wouldn't I certainly wouldn't be an
artist if I wasn't a songwriter it's
kind of been like the compass for me and
the just like the truth I wrote it when
I was 19. like it just had this magic on
it it's interesting because I've learned
the more like like brutally honest I am
I think I'm losing my fear of like was
that an overshare I'm just kind of like
that definitely wasn't over share and
that's all right the 29 year old first
started writing music at 12 years old
because of her parents divorce it was
like this thing that helped me as an
only child and I was just like whoa my
life feels chaotic it's like I had the
vision of like I was like in Rapids and
like I needed a branch and songwriting
with my branch and it has been through
my whole life it's been my my way of
remembering
every moment and every season of my life
and bookmarking it and sometimes making
it sound boppy and sometimes like
letting it sound like I was crying when
I wrote it because it probably was and
letting both things exist in the same
space because that's life
[Music]
is like picking a favorite kid I don't
think you're allowed to do that I think
it just depends on like what I'm
connecting with at that point I think it
just depends on where I'm at emotionally
sometimes I want to get real sassy and
miss me more gets like 45 more of a hair
flip it just depends Kelsey is taking
those hair flips on the road starting
next week so what does our pre-show
ritual look like
this is how I know that I'm in my late
20s when I was starting out I was like
tequila shot with the band before the
show I would never warm up I would just
walk on just be like here we go I'm here
and now I'm like 10 minute warm up hot
tea honey I can't can't have alcohol
before like it just I or maybe I just
like am taking care of myself more
you'll just catch me like with like a
steamer and a glass of hot tea super
sexy really really hot
[Music]